construida en la Península de maní la
capital petrolera y económica de gabón
estaba amenazada por el calentamiento
global actualmente la ciudad está tan
solo cuatro metros por encima del nivel
del mar
este faro Centenario es el recordatorio
constante del cambio climático
diseñado por el ingeniero francés
gustave la estructura de hierro y cobre
del Cabo López podría desaparecer del
mapa a causa de la erosión
el presidente de la ong h20 Michelle no
puede hacerse a la idea del peor de los
escenarios junto con otros activistas
medioambientales monitorea cada semana
la subida del nivel del mar esta Barrera
en concreto se dirigió hace unos años
para proteger a coatlantil de los
aumentos del nivel de las aguas Angry
Michelle y su equipo instan a las
autoridades locales a actuar con rapidez
hay algunas soluciones la primera sería
tratar de disminuir el aumento del nivel
del mar
plantando manglares naturales y
manglares artificiales en áreas de mucho
tráfico
la segunda solución es mover la ciudad
lejos de la costa eso es lo que han
hecho a otras ciudades costeras en
Estados Unidos en Países Bajos entre
otras sería la mejor solución y la más
barata
es la segunda ciudad más grande de gabón
y el centro de la industria petrolera y
maderera del país pero ubicarla
significaría mover a más de 100.000
personas a pesar de los recurrentes
episodios de inundación los residentes
quieren evitar esa solución a toda costa
fátimate y sus vecinos viven en un
barrio marginal donde la temporada de
lluvia significa más inundaciones cuando
hay demasiada agua utilizan estos palets
de madera para acceder a sus casas los
palets nos ayudan a acceder a nuestras
casas cuando terminamos de bañarnos sin
tener que caminar por el agua estamos en
porcentil la ciudad Está rodeada de agua
a donde nos van a mover no podemos ir a
ningún lugar donde no haya agua
Honestamente la vida es muy difícil para
nosotros aquí para evitar mover la
ciudad entera las autoridades locales
están duplicando sus esfuerzos para
mitigar el riesgo de inundaciones se ha
convertido en una carrera contrarreloj
por arreglar y limpiar el sistema de
drenaje de 20 kilómetros
a qué hora empezaron 8 de la mañana bien
entonces empezamos Aquí y ahora que
sigue Vamos hasta el semáforo verdad
el director de planeación urbana dentil
Racing B supervisa el proceso de
limpieza este proyecto de rehabilitación
tiene un costo estimado de más de 50
millones de euros
la ciudad dentil no puede ganar esta
batalla sola porque necesita muchos
recursos necesitaremos el apoyo de
nuestros aliados internacionales y del
Gobierno Federal hemos notado algo
Bastante alarmante la combinación de
lluvias fuertes y mareas altas es lo que
eleva los niveles la red existente tiene
dificultades para evacuar el agua y eso
termina causando inundaciones
los expertos gaboneses afirman que los
aumentos del nivel del mar también
podrían amenazar las principales
plataformas petrolíferas de postgram
till que contribuyen hasta en un 40% al
pib Nacional
Los investigadores del Centro Nacional
de datos y consejo marítimo vigilan de
cerca el efecto del calentamiento global
en las corrientes marítimas
el azul oscuro representa las corrientes
débiles
el azul claro las corrientes intermedias
luego ha de verde a rojo
litoral de cierre moganga es bastante
pesimista respecto al futuro sinopía
arriba en el peor de los casos lo
primero que veremos es la
intensificación de la erosión costera y
la repetición de inundaciones
con una elevación costera tan baja
el agua tendrá dificultades para
disiparse
desafortunadamente ambos fenómenos
crearán una situación en la que para
2050 seríamos testigos de una topografía
totalmente nueva en la Península de
Majin
los científicos japoneses previene que
el nivel del mar podría subir más de 6
metros para el año 2050 muy por encima
de la elevación de post